the supreme court is allowing evictions
to resume blocking a temporary
moratorium ban from the biden
administration and the cdc uh the
supreme court now decided the cdc lacked
the authority to stop evictions during
the pandemic hector mejia is joining us
live this morning with more on what this
ruling means good morning hector
[Music]
hey there joe good morning to you we
heard about this ruling yesterday
evening so this is huge news this
morning for landlords and tenants facing
eviction especially without a moratorium
in place however there are some things
tenants can do nevada legal aid experts
are providing some advice in a tweet
last night bailey bertolin policy
director said quote while this is
disappointing nevadans should not panic
we have a plan apply for rental
assistance respond to all eviction
notices by filing an answer with the
court include that you have a pending
rental assistance application and choose
mediation she says you should not be
evicted she went on to say we can make
tenants and landlords whole and help
everyone move forward the legal aid
center of southern nevada encourages
property owners to work with renters
through a coronavirus relief housing
assistance program known as chap if you
have any questions you can call the
center their phone number is
702-386-1070 their office hours are 8 30
a.m to 4 30 p.m monday through friday
and also the whole eviction process can
be confusing if you have some time
tomorrow and if you are facing eviction
there is a clinic happening over at
desert breeze community center that is
over by spring mountain road and
cimarron the event is happening from 10
a.m to 1 in the afternoon the legal aid
center is providing attorneys and other
professionals to provide some one-on-one
assistance to people facing eviction
reporting live this morning hector mejia
8 news now